Well go to your mom's house,
Christina.
One,
two,
one,
three
15 genes
minds.
Me and my high school days going through industrial clubs.
We played this last week.
Oh,
I think I said the same thing.
It's
right.
It's right.
Fucking write
a good song.
Really good
digging it man,
as I recall,
right?
Yeah.
Any Cominos ball?
You like on the circumcise guys as I recall.
Right.
I love it.
It's like the concierge asking him.
It is p p thanks Tj.
I recall.
Um,
thanks to everybody that came out to five sold out shows.
Oh Hi.
Oh Cleveland steamer.
Then I'm your boy old jumbo.
Ding Dong over here.
I have um,
Spokane sperm.
Can Washington at the all new sperm can comedy club.
April 21st through 23rd May 5th,
May 7th Jack's me offs and Bill Florida at the comedy zone there.
Um,
sewer juice,
New York.
May 20th and 21st at the funny bone and sear my pubes New York.
Good.
Um,
and then uh,
New York Shit.
Newport titties.
Um,
you guys are on the schedule right now.
You are nicer.
Wrong one.
Sorry.
You are not till September,
but they're already on sale.
It's Caroline's.
September 8th,
ninth and 10th and then far her delta.
Pete,
Pete Fart.
Fill her up,
fill her up to the uh,
Pennsylvania.
So Trocadero theatre November 19th.
It's a long ways away.
Sounds like I don't need to buy my tickets.
It's more than half sold out.
Um,
and it's in November.
So Trocadero theatre,
get them now while you can barge.
Um,
April 7th at the Irvine Improv.
Eight o'clock show come there.
April 7th and then um,
April 20th at the Harbor Material Harbor Comedy Club,
right?
Yeah.
Ventura County and plenty of Hitler's birthday.
And then May 27th of May 28th it's La Jolla comedy store.
La Jolla.
That's fancy San Diego.
Yeah.
That's real nice in Lajolla.
That's real nice.
May 27 my time.
And then every Saturday night I'm usually at the comedy store.
Eight o'clock show,
not the Saturday.
Cause we have family coming into town.
We sure do.
But usually I plan on being there.
This show today is loaded with com.
Yeah,
man.
You ready to do this?
I'm ready to get into this.
I feel like I know or this is going and I will tell you that's weird.
I like it already.
We start to show them in.
Yeah.
Fuck boys out there.
Just trying to talk shit against me.
Oh,
okay.
I see you have a gun.
Do you?
You have a gun deal.
I'll put down my weapon out,
down to my weapon.
I will put down my weapon.
I got another fucking sword,
bitch.
Well,
well,
well go to your mom's house,
Christina.
My audience moving then man.
Horrible
does that.
It's really cool.
I was reading that first ad and you were searching for your email.
You're like,
oh,
sorry.
So that first ad has you just it,
you know,
because 5,000 different people send us the copy,
right?
I don't know who the fuck to look for.
Hey,
take it easy.
This isn't this so demeaning.
Look at this like a goat.
You are a goat.
That's why they call you goat lips.
You have trouble finding the fucking ads.
Why don't you just,
linkedin is helpful.
There's Linkedin and get all the ads there.
Length.
Dennis,
how length is how Dennis helpful?
Nobody actually uses link.
I feel like linkedin only exist to be invited to use it and then nobody really
uses it once the loud you to their linkedin profile.
I always wanting to add but never really using no thanks.
Don't want anything to do with you.
Um,
linkedin.
What a great first of all.
Yeah,
I like it.
Cool.
Your first boyfriend has a video app and again,
it kind of reminds me of him.
Um,
no,
but,
uh,
this dude,
he's not playing games while you fuck boys.
I think fuck boy is one of my favorite saying like,
fuck boy,
what does it mean?
Is it is,
it's,
it's a,
it's a demeaning.
You're a bitch of a bitch of a man.
You're not even a man.
You're a fuckboy fuck.
It's a huge insult.
Have you heard?
Fuck boy.
Yeah.
It's,
no,
it's no good man.
I like it.
It's kind of,
you know,
where it came from.
I think it came out of the fact that,
uh,
it's,
it's socially unacceptable to basically say faggot.
Right?
Oh,
okay.
It's like an anger at fuck is,
is,
is pejorative.
It's full of venom.
And it's,
I think it's like almost like a replacement for that,
so instead of fag,
you're not saying,
fuck boy.
Yeah.
It's,
it's meant to be really insulting.
Right.
And I think it's something that people can yell,
right.
Without being like,
Hey,
what watches off c version of Faggot?
I think so.
Yeah.
I really feel like the it is.
Well,
I like,
fuck boy.
If I can't say Faggot,
I'm going to say fuck boy.
It sounds like you're already doing it.
Sounds like it worked.
I think I like this new system.
Yeah.
About this is how you get around the political,
correct.
It is.
You just find a new word for the same thing.
That's exactly what's happening.
Yeah.
I'm on board looking for that new end bomb.
If you know anyone,
any suggestion,
but you fuck boys out there trying to talk shit against me.
Oh.
I like how slowly he puts it away.
You have a gun deal.
I'll put down my weapon out down my west.
Okay.
I will send down my weapon.
I got another fucking sword.
You fucking bitch.
Yeah,
I love him.
Yeah.
He's talking that shit.
This guy could have very well dated.
You definitely could have dated that guy.
Yeah.
He reminds me and Christian Slater a little bit from the 90s.
Ah,
yeah.
I don't know something about him.
It's fucking funny,
man.
I would ask what's going on there,
but it's like,
why bother at this point?
Yeah.
Why,
why even ask?
I used to care and now I'm like,
you know what,
it's just worlds.
Just the world.
The world sees what happens when you do 338 episodes.
My Mom's house,
I don't even know where to start with a this going on
this weekend.
Um,
or with this,
this show,
there's so many things to talk about.
Um,
you know,
one of the great things that happened was this weekend.
Oh God.
Are we going to talk about this already?
The only we should,
I think it's pretty good idea.
Oh Jesus.
Fuck.
Here's your boy.
Can I,
thanks for coming out to flappers guys.
What a fun weekend.
Bourbon.
That's your boy.
Dj Dad Mouth.
I saw,
so did you make the horn sounds,
was that you actually DJ?
Yes.
Yeah.
And then you went and then I screwed up.
He did it kind of,
you know,
like,
this is my first time.
Yeah.
Yeah,
for sure.
It was,
how'd it feel?
It felt amazing.
I've never had so much joy.
I even texted you a picture of myself smiling ear to ear saying,
I can't sleep because I'm just thinking about my deejaying career.
Cause I canceled all the rest of my standup dates for the year.
Um,
so here's what happened.
I'm in,
uh,
Cleveland all yeah.
Doing shows.
And I see on Twitter,
somebody tags me a tweet.
Oh,
so cool that,
uh,
Tom Segura and Hannibal Burress,
or in Cleveland at the same time,
if I look at Hannibal's page and he's doing a popup show,
we're like,
oh,
I have two shows tonight.
Maybe I can get him to come over on the early show.
So I send him a text.
I said,
are you,
are you in town?
Do you want to come in,
pop and do a guest spot on my early show?
And he says,
sure.
So he comes by the,
the club and he has his DJ.
Uh,
he does,
he has a DJ that he brings to all his shows.
Right.
Tony Trimm,
who's a great guy and I just met that night.
I love Hannibal,
by the way.
I haven't seen him in a minute,
but I really like that and it was great.
So first of all,
uh,
I have a video of him hitting the stage.
The djs name Tony Trim.
Tony Trimm.
Yeah.
Deejays.
Why do all Djs have like the coolest personality?
He's the coolest guy.
I know.
They all are.
Yeah.
You may want to hang out with him for sure.
[inaudible] Jay scratch starting from scratch.
Yeah.
Hung out with that guy in,
in London and spend bad,
there are the fucking coolest dudes because we,
what they like,
you know,
they love music,
so yeah.
I mean they love it.
They like having a good time.
They're DJ's.
Yeah.
And they're kind of down to earth cause I feel like deejaying,
it's a real humble gig in the beginning.
Much like stand up,
which is why they usually,
you click with them.
Yeah.
It's the same grass roots effort.
Like,
does anyone want to hear me Dj?
Yeah,
fuck you asshole.
And it takes 10 years,
like really getting good.
I love your scratch.
Yeah.
That's really
key.
Is graduate to have a big record.
Make her use two hands.
So anyways,
I these guys both see me getting really excited.
Oh No,
no,
I'm jumping ahead.
Yeah.
Handled,
does a guest spot.
I have a video of him hitting the stage,
that place he rubbed it.
I mean it was like you announced,
guess what George Carlin isn't dead.
He's right here.
Like they went fucking crazy,
which was cool to watch.
Yeah.
Uh,
and then he set the tone.
It was great.
Um,
and also I should say bill squire was on the shows,
the full charge coming back to the west coast.
Got then did me a favor doing those shows.
So it was great.
So anyways,
then panels like I'm going to do my show on the other side of town,
other side of town,
meaning 600 miles away.
And he says,
uh,
if you want afterwards,
ah,
I'm having,
I'm throwing an after party and this is what he does this in a lot of cities
like finds a place after his show and has a party and you know,
obviously Dj is Dj doesn't just do his live show.
He does the after party.
You want to come?
I go,
sure.
And then he texts me,
I'll let you DJ a few songs.
Oh my God.
Did your Dick just explode off your I was like,
I started texting him love letters.
I was like,
dude,
this is a map.
No Ha.
Sorry.
How to handle all know that you were interested in Dj.
He just knows,
I mean we've,
we've talked about music before but then he saw,
I mean right there I was like asking the Dj all about equipment.
So he was watching,
he was watching us.
Yeah.
And May I say for the record,
Hannibal Buress is a type of gentlemen who should have yes.
Yes.
A Dj,
Huh?
Opening friendly.
He's a cool,
it's cool dude.
Yeah.
Like it's a mellow dude.
I can see him being like,
I love it.
This is part of his,
his steeze,
you know,
talking about it.
How,
when,
when Tony is not available.
I was like,
is that the worst?
He's like,
yeah,
absolutely.
Because I liked the vibe that it says it's your show and you know,
then I,
then I'm asking you a sound guy.
Can you do this?
What?
Yeah.
It's like,
it's the most impossible request.
Well,
like this weekend at full pairs,
I did my shows and they're great.
Thank you for asking.
And I requested a song.
How were you?
Shows that they were amazing.
Yeah.
So Super Fun.
You had,
um,
I old Maryland rice cub of who?
I love Dave Ryan.
It's my homie.
Yeah.
Anyways,
I asked the,
you know,
the Dj,
can you just bring me up to like John Spencer Blues Explosion?
Who,
okay.
The song is called two kinds of law.
What's that?
And then how far in should I start?
I'm like,
dude,
just fucking make it good.
Yeah,
you're the DJ.
you fucking,
I,
you should know these things and you know what?
That's your fuck one job.
Could I hired this guy,
right,
right.
Dj Dan,
Marketo burned me out of whatever.
Just fucking
can I compliment you on your,
like you got down.
What djs do,
like the pointing and the course,
you know it's all coming together.
It's still,
that looks fucking Funkmaster
flex right there.
You do look like you.
You could be a DJ though.
I'm going to be a DJ.
No,
I am going to Dj.
Yeah,
no,
no.
I can,
I can hear the sarcasm response.
What's great about our garage is that it's really soundproofed let me finish.
So this is the best news ever.
So why?
Then I get a message from him.
So he's like,
you know,
come,
hang out.
And you're like,
okay,
I'm going to come.
I have two shows.
I have a show that starts at,
you know,
nine 30 10 I'm going to get it.
And you're like,
I'm going to go.
But you're,
it's still like,
I got to get in a car and go across town.
I get offstage and handle was no,
we're going to do the after party at the club that you're at at the comedy club.
Oh even better.
So I like that's the,
you don't have to go anywhere,
you know,
the only thing better would be like,
it's in your hotel.
So,
so he shows up with Tony,
they,
you know,
they set up in the lounge,
people are hanging out having drinks,
he sets up and then I go up there and I go,
can I get like a little tutorial?
They,
they each are showing me stuff with Tony is like giving me kind of a crash
course and you know,
he's like,
oh,
you're not intimidated by buttons.
When I go,
I think I actually doing this show,
I go,
you know,
I'm always playing drops,
adjusting things.
And is this similar to what it's not.
I mean,
it's not on board.
They have a board there that,
you know,
I think he was plugged into,
it's just that the,
his actual,
it's,
you know,
two basically two turntables and a microphone.
Yeah.
At a mixer.
It's all,
he has an all in one board.
It's just that remembering,
oh,
this does this and that does that.
I can memorize that and not be like,
what is all this right away?
I don't know what I'm doing,
but I'm saying electronic devices that have different functions don't make me
go,
I'm not doing anything with that.
It's not as daunting.
So I'm starting to learn the thing,
you know,
the very basics.
Um,
I'm starting to,
I have him take a picture and video.
I sent it to you and then we're laughing so hard at your responses because your
responses are like,
no,
you should be embarrassed.
This is embarrassing.
Like so,
so demeaning.
The,
so gay,
fuck boy gay can't say,
yeah,
you're,
it's just like,
and then I keep telling him,
I'm like,
I keep showing them the messages and I'm like,
I just enjoy this.
He was like,
dude,
I'm going to give you free Skype lessons.
I'm going to get you in that.
Tony Trimm.
Thanks Tony for the free lessons via Skype.
What are you doing to my life?
Having fun?
We're having fun.
God dammit.
So anyways,
I had an absolute blast doing that.
I have ordered no,
yes,
I ordered the same equipment he has.
Okay,
great.
Um,
how much of an investment is that?
It's under $15,000.
Okay.
Well,
sorry,
a little jeans.
You don't need diapers and dad's got a scratch board.
Your baby doesn't need a formula or closed dead scratch in this weekend.
And Yeah,
Cleveland,
it's pretty good.
So no,
it's absolutely not expensive actually.
You would,
you'd be surprised.
Yeah,
seriously.
I don't need to know.
You don't need to know.
I need to fill me in.
We don't need to talk about it that seriously.
It's funny.
This,
yeah,
it's far less than the laptop.
Oh,
that's cool.
Yeah.
So it's not,
it's not a crazy thing.
It's like buying a keyboard.
Sure.
Yeah.
You know why?
Because it's one of those things where as time progressed and it,
they made it easier for people to access things.
It drove the price of things.
Why does everything,
Yeah.
Um,
now this may be a dumb question,
but do the Djs use records anymore?
It's all you can there.
I mean you can as this is plugged in with a computer.
Wow.
So you go to your iTunes.
Yeah.
And you're like,
yeah.
So then how do they blend the two songs together?
How do you do that?
That's part of the,
there's a mixer in the board.
I feel like I'm a thousand years and it has a built in horn drop.
As long as you do the horn,
drop my fine and also has gunshots.
Here's what I mean.
Really.
I'm not,
I'm,
I'm going to come out and say it right now.
Okay.
I feel like,
yes,
I'm going to put it,
it's going to be obviously in the garage.
It's gonna be something I do recreationally for fun.
When I get to the point where I'm not like obviously going to be a professional
DJ,
but when it gets to the point where I have a,
um,
a decent command of how to,
you know,
get songs playing,
moving together,
like I have some command of,
of this board,
I am going to do a show somewhere.
I don't know what city will be.
And then I'm going to have an after party where I'm going to bring that shit and
we're going to
all right.
A live party.
I think you should do it.
Dj,
Dad,
Matthew J.
Dad Mountain to Dj Dad math or is it typically by,
I feel like dad mouth is who I am.
Yeah.
I feel like,
uh,
I feel like that's the right Dj name for me.
Yeah.
Plus it's a huge shout out to your mom's house listeners,
which let's face it will be your only audience in the beginning.
Maybe in the beginning.
Yeah.
Until you really build that a beef following.
Are you going to be fun to spam?
Yeah.
Um,
am I am.
I feel like that'll be on the,
you know,
on the leg of it.
I feel like it'll be kind of like Spokane,
Syracuse.
He be fast.
Something that was a huge Dj.
I know you have to go to Miami to like pay.
I got a,
sorry,
I got a book,
a Miami Gig Asap.
Miami.
And then you've got to do Vegas.
That's where all the Djs and you love Vegas.
That's the cool thing is now you get to go to all your favorite cities.
Las Vegas,
Miami.
The best thing about it,
if I be fat,
if I do at Miami Gig is that I can
do the gig and be like,
Hey,
my DJ set starts at midnight and Miami's like,
that's what time I'm waking up.
Yeah,
sure.
Let me tell you something.
What I love about this deejaying Gig yeah.
Is that it really combines everything you love in life,
which is staying up late.
Yeah.
Late nights hanging out with tons of strangers.
Loud music.
Yeah.
Your favorite places like Vegas,
Miami,
these are all things that just say Tom Segura exclusively.
Um,
lights.
Just like that whole rowdy sort of,
I see you then.
That is your lane.
So you've really found a good lane.
Stay with it.
Tom.
Ever seen so happy.
Yeah.
Ever see me happy?
And then you tweeted,
yeah,
when I tweeted this out,
I hate seeing you.
So happy.
Yeah.
I give you,
I give you two or three of these before you're like,
I don't know,
two or three what gigs.
Here's,
here's my prediction.
Dj Dad mouth after two shows on a late night Saturday.
Yeah.
And you're like,
oh,
I got this thing lined up to Dj and then after him are on 1230 midnight after
you've done your two and two and a half,
three hours of standup.
Yeah.
Exhausted.
You flown across the country and you've been up doing press that morning at 5:00
AM you're going to be dreading it and then you know you'll do it and he'll be
like,
I wish I didn't have a fucking DJ tonight and wait until you see the crowds.
I have just like how they just jump
Ben and singing and dancing.
It's going to be crazy.
I can't wait.
I'm going to call Macio and then I get some tips from him too.
Okay.
Why don't you talk to Dj scratch starting from scratch.
I might talk to you.
Yeah,
that guy is cool.
It Shit.
Yeah,
they're all just the other dude.
They're all cool man.
Um,
oh,
so I probably should have left that up.
Want to fucking kill myself to you put this.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Here it is by the way.
Um,
do you know you haven't seen it yet,
but I was in,
when I was in Cleveland,
I stopped by the,
uh,
local morning TV show.
Yeah.
And I,
oh,
I probably should open it here.
I,
um,
I did a little interview.
It looks good.
And uh,
WWE people were digging it,
man.
You know,
I,
I did something that you might not be expecting,
but I just wanted to show you,
you know,
we are,
and we welcome a guy like this onto the show.
Welcome Ohio Native Comedian Thompson Gora folks.
So,
okay.
Before we get into this set out to everybody all over the world doing their
thing and stuff like that,
shout out to dany acts x Vlp
you know what I'm saying?
Got It.
So,
okay,
this guy,
I didn't want to know anything about him before he came on.
I thought it was a lot of mystery behind these sunglasses.
I started asking him some questions like,
you know what,
I'm just going to stop.
So this is one big surprise coming up here.
So I first want to welcome you tell you,
I think you have the coolest style of any comedian that has come on the show.
I appreciate you.
Thank you.
This is your,
this is your lock normally
coming from Ohio,
being from Cincinnati,
like where do you kind of get your inspiration,
I guess from your clothes,
you know,
from the streets.
Mostly I travel,
I just picked it up from,
you know,
fight,
fight and people,
you know,
beef in like I got this,
I don't know.
Why aren't you had some beef with crazy low cost.
Yeah.
It's funny you mentioned those.
So he's this rapper from San Jose,
right?
That has been challenging me on youtube wanting to fight.
Physically fight.
Yeah.
He wants to step in the ring and he's been working out at like target and
Walmart training and stuff.
Yup.
And you know,
I just want him to know that I've been in home depot and staples and I've been
throwing around like two by fours and I'm just ready to get down.
I just want him,
you know what I'm saying?
I want him to know,
you feel me.
Don't talk back.
I'm saying that I'm ready to do this.
So whenever he wants to step in the ring,
we can get down.
All right,
well that's a challenge.
All right.
Oh,
that's a challenge actually.
I got to get her,
she really went with the whole role.
What's your roll with it?
Yeah.
What a horrible job.
Her job.
I mean,
well,
yeah,
I mean the thing I was thinking about too is how many of the,
um,
of the other morning shows I've done where they would've just been like,
we got to go.
They just came out.
Yeah.
I want the whole world to know that just reached out to crazy low so we can,
we can do this whenever he wants to do it.
Okay.
Well I don't want to mess with you then.
Do you do this with other comedians to,
do you get into these?
Uh,
I mean,
if they want to feel these hands,
yeah,
they shouldn't.
They can.
They can let me know and I'll let them know right back.
You know,
I try to keep it,
you know,
pretty easy.
Most of the time if I'm deejaying or if I'm Dj as well.
Yeah.
I'll be deejaying this weekend here.
I'm a tweet out a location for a pop up show,
so I'll be,
I didn't even realize that.
How fucking serendipitous that was because that was before the
call.
That too.
Yeah.
Stand up.
I'll be doing some,
some sites.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Gymnastics.
I do that.
I mean,
I hear you laughing,
but I'm actually pretty damn good at.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean I could do,
if I wanted to,
I could do six flips right here.
Right now.
Bam,
Bam.
But if we didn't have these cameras right here,
I would,
and I don't want to pay that,
but yeah.
Jim just as well,
gymnast.
I'm an trainer.
I train dogs.
Um,
I can train.
I am actually one of the few guys that can train cats.
It's too,
by the way,
that was the closest I came to laughing really hard.
I had to bite my lip a little bit when I said that.
I was like,
it's so stupid.
So
lot of people,
what's the coolest thing?
I'm about to laugh right there.
Uh,
probably answer a phone.
Mister Jinx with the
flushing the toilet.
Did they know how to do that too?
I tried to cat if he could,
if he hears the phone ring.
Yeah,
he could hit the speaker phone button.
That's what you're calling.
He's,
let me see your hand
moves the hand.
Somebody was going,
oh,
I hate that.
I ruined the phone.
Yeah.
Betty ways.
You know,
I put it out there man.
So great.
So they must have heard your call.
I feel like the,
the world,
but I'm also talking about locally,
I put it out there for looks,
you know.
Oh,
right.
Yeah.
I mean,
um,
it's pretty,
uh,
and by the way,
where'd you find that?
The what you sent me?
How'd you get ahold of that?
Yeah.
Today.
Wow.
Okay.
Your iPad,
it's probably the worst moment in the history of the show right now.
It's probably the worst moment ever in the history of,
of your mom's house is listening to you during that,
so,
so check this out.
Okay.
Thanks man.
Um,
so I did that on local press in Cleveland.
And then this morning this comes on,
just comes into us and just tell me what you think of this shit.
Oh Shit.
Yeah,
that's the right answer.
Everybody doing their claim,
rocking,
beat boxing production.
The best boxing promoter,
the tool nine has to offer.
Shout out to the leaders voice.
If you ever want to step up to a real promoter,
it's way too fucking long.
But here's the thing that happens in about this guy talks for a while,
talks a lot of shit.
You know you want to talk some shit and then after a little,
yeah.
So you have now woken a four so great that he cannot be restrained and she's
your girl lock.
I kid you have rattled the lion's cage.
I know what you think.
He's got in there.
Crazy low.
Oh No.
And stuff like that.
She will get it cracking and stuff like that.
Let's get it cracking at GM and stuff like that.
No retail store can get on some logos and stuff like that.
A cracking and stuff like that.
You'll fill me for reals.
Dope.
Cause get it on that channel eight and stuff.
Crazy notes is ready to step up and step in the ring and whatever way you think
you're ready at crazy notes can be ready.
He is a fitness level.
His cardio
that was your black eyes or is that pain?
Doesn't that look like black eyes?
It's an iron deficiency.
Okay,
this is amazing.
This is amazing.
This guy found crazy lugs.
He did.
This guy was at my show and Sacramento.
And did he give you a heads up like hey he was like one of the front row guys
that I talked to,
you know like throughout that show and then he went and found crazy lows.
Yeah,
he's dedication in his knowledge of boxing is more in his real finger.
Then you got to do a rather large and okay
your answer 20 20th she got for the man.
I'll take you out to not take your wife and shout goes after Tom Segura and
shout was after Christina a by God blessed.
We all keep it pushing.
We got,
he's been talking mess about off.
I'm a north cow.
We've got to concentrate now.
We got to keep it pushing,
but I gotta keep it pushing
one of the greatest moments in my life.
Crazy luck.
Just made it crazy.
So crazy.
This has never happened.
Like we never get to get this far with our,
um,
our subjects.
Yeah.
This is amazing.
What's going to happen?
Are we going to do this?
Well,
there's a little more.
Okay.
Shout out to everybody.
Rocking me.
Ample crazy.
Mr Segura,
we're going to await short answer.
We have to come to so cowed or whether you like come up to northern California
to the get to as you have referred them to.
I referred to that
it cracky that's what I'm talking about.
We're ready.
Sure.
We'll be waiting and gotten no response.
Move the government and everybody doing their sign.
Kuma wrap on the way out.
Quiz
loads from the mica straight to us.
Right until it was so good.
Hope you understand.
I keep it so chill when I spit and they'll feel bored.
I said,
have a straight to phone Pharma.
He affirmed at temple for no brainer.
Chris in Los is a thug,
is going to maintain it in every way.
No play.
Okay.
So yeah,
I'm sorry,
I'm just processing it.
I don't feel like I can't,
my brain can't comprehend it.
So this dude on the REIT owns a restaurant.
Mm.
And that came up during the show.
Um,
many ways.
He was like,
we were just talking about that.
And then I think it was,
I forget how far it is from,
I think he said he just drove two hours to meet crazy legs.
Oh my God.
So at the end of this video,
because this ends here pretty quickly,
right?
Yeah.
And then it's like,
it's just him making a video that he actually shot on the way to meet crazy.
Lokes um,
so I guess he took to heart the,
uh,
you know,
the part where before I was saying we could do,
we could get together and sell tickets and do a charity thing.
He is suggesting we do one for mental health awareness.
Hey,
that's great.
Let's do it.
Well,
we just have to figure out what exactly are we selling tickets to.
It's really up to you.
So Laura,
I know you said I could spar him,
but I mean come on.
I don't know.
Is that really?
Does that a good idea?
Yeah.
Let's,
let's marinate on this amount.
Maybe deejaying challenge.
Go lokes isn't a Dj's is a rapper.
Hello?
So you want to do a show with them?
Yes,
obviously.
And then the greatest rappers,
one of the greatest Dj's alive.
Oh my God.
Together.
Do you think you could sell tickets to that?
I think to our fans,
we could.
I mean,
if you're,
if you're donating to charity,
you're not selling tickets to,
you know,
actually for what you're doing in nor cal or so cow.
We'll do in nor cal.
I think that's an idea.
I don't,
I'm not saying it's set in stone,
but I think that's a good idea.
Okay,
well here's another idea.
Okay.
Hear me out.
All right.
Why don't we do a fucking your mom's house podcast live.
Oh yeah.
And invite crazy looks down and you,
and do that and make it like a fucking massive,
your mom's house event.
That's a good idea.
And then maybe the big finale is you and crazy lokes deejaying and you guys can
kind of prepare and you know.
Yeah.
And we can,
that will be really crazy.
Crazier than crazy,
crazy,
crazy looks.
What do you think?
So kind of good idea.
And we can get a huge venue.
I think this is going to be Norco.
Norco.
No.
So cow do it down here.
You got to bring crazy looks down dude.
We go up there.
Okay,
well see that's what I think we did.
I think we'd go up there and do it.
Okay.
Because you could also everybody,
we could,
you know,
invite the,
every Sacramento listener,
every San Jose,
San Francisco Scouts could come out to be a big thing.
Look,
let's,
I think that's a great idea.
That'd be really fun.
No.
And how much we have to donate to charity.
Yeah,
we could do that would be good.
That'd be awesome.
I can't,
I can't believe this happened.
Um,
it's very surreal when they actually talk back to you.
Yeah.
It's a very weird,
the dude,
the video,
he's like,
you got my email.
I'll have your email.
It says the emails in this where you don't put it on the screen.
Where's your email?
Yeah,
we got out of the g though his oh no.
that's what I'm saying.
No,
no,
the guys,
I feel like we got to go through him.
Yeah,
I know.
But do you have his email?
Crazy one?
No,
no,
no.
The guy his,
yeah,
he met.
He's the one that said it is.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right,
cool.
Wow.
Do you know what this feels like?
The TV's talking to you,
you know?
Yeah,
I know.
Like what,
it's so weird to see my name in a video like this,
you know?
Right.
Yeah.
Dan Did sub like that.
So stuff like that.
This is crazy.
This is a big shout out to everyone all over the world is really doing their
thing.
Um,
well I just have that is exciting.
That is so fucking funny and so good man.
Can believe it.
It was also the district's diss tracks were in that crazy looks folder.
Yeah.
Uh,
MC.
Now I'm saying,
oh my gosh.
Okay.
We'll go out on one of those.
Um,
that's huge
to uh,
I,
I haven't even seen it so I just want to know because this is like something
that I figured like you probably need to watch
see where it is high.
So yeah,
we were sending,
this is my official you of eating ass.
Okay.
This is something that I feel like you need to watch with.
I think you need to pay a little better attention to,
right.
This is like one of the courses you didn't do well in school,
you know,
so it's like,
hey,
you got to go.
But was it something that I'm,
hopefully it hits you in the heart,
you know,
you're ready.
What else did you do this weekend?
Any see any movie?
Hi.
So this video is my official for you.
She's like 12 of eating ashes.
This we can true.
Suddenly I had the pleasure of eating ass.
People have asked me then I said,
why?
And I say,
why not?
We have asked me how was it?
Yeah.
And I have given lots of slot into this question and I have decided that it
would be best that I just make a general view in my one experience.
She's um,
I don't know if she put the music on for this moment though,
right?
Yeah,
no.
First of all,
I rate the experience is 6.5 out of 10.
That's not rationally.
I rated it a six,
but I gave it some thought and I think a 6.5 is more fitting.
I just really want you to think about that on the terms of how enjoyable it
might be for you.
You know,
damn dog,
he's our dog.
Um,
I guess I weigh out the pros and cons.
Pros and eating ass.
The other person on Juliet.
Thank you,
joy.
Thank you.
No one cares about that.
Your spouse
people.
Another pro is that it doesn't taste bad.
Most people think that.
So I'm gonna think about which dumbed,
yeah,
it's bad or they think it will taste like,
but it doesn't go exactly like any,
that's so dumb body person at all.
Okay.
If I let something that has jelly coming out of it,
it's going to taste like jelly coming out of a donut that has the chocolate
coming out of it in the hall.
Then looks like chocolate chocolate coming out.
There's no chocolate coming in.
The chocolate lives there,
but it's not coming out the chocolate.
It smells like the container from which it comes.
It's,
you know,
like when you,
you keep something in a bowl or something and it retains the olders.
It's how you have to sterilize it so that it doesn't,
she's crazy.
This person who's telling you crazy like a dany act
for whatever reason,
it just,
it doesn't taste like anything.
There you go.
So hard to do chocolate.
So can I have my coffee?
The pros,
the cons would be,
I would say the biggest time is this smell.
It doesn't smell that great.
Then how does it taste?
Tastes good.
If it smells bad,
dub down.
She says it doesn't smell that great.
Well what?
Come on man.
That's a very distinct,
I mean the witness said,
okay,
it doesn't smell great and he's good.
That could imply that it smells good but not great.
My granny used to cook a few things that didn't smell great,
but I'm sure they taste good.
You could also ask the person to
wash their ass real quick before there's not a problem.
The smallest pleasant,
but the smells very bearable.
I would say it's from this morning.
Another con would be sometimes this person has not shaped their ass and that's
totally fine.
I can take care of that too.
But if you're not a fan of hair,
then you probably won't appreciate.
How mortified would you be?
Just if you were,
uh,
you know,
older,
a little older parents,
you see this video of your dad,
you're like,
of all the videos she could pose,
do the amount of hair that to potentially be somebody.
I think that's it for the cons.
So essentially the cons,
the pros way of the coms.
Thank you.
Um,
and so,
you know,
I read it a 6.5.
I didn't think it was that bad at all.
I was expecting worse and it wasn't that bad.
Um,
so now that we got the review out of the way,
I would also like to address something that I was pretty upset about after this
event happened.
I was very upset after I eat us because of the amount of people who I've heard
say,
I don't need us.
Okay.
How are you done with us?
This is good.
Look into those eyes and she's looking at you right now.
Okay.
All right.
Yeah,
we can be done,
but I just want you to think about it a little bit.
Did I mention the movie that I narrated is out?
Do you have the names I can pull up?
Said the film I narrated.
It's,
um,
it's out and,
you know,
festivals and whatnot.
It's called can we take a joke?
I'm the narrator.
Gilbert Godfrey,
Lisa Lampanelli,
Penn Jillette is in it.
And it's about the,
how political correctness is destroying the comedy world.
Um,
pretty interesting stuff.
And did you know that there's a comedian being sued right now in Canada?
I sure did.
Yeah.
Ah,
it's just heartbreaking.
They're really strict law about saying fuck boys and making fun of people.
Boy That's really lame.
I love you Canada.
But that's lame.
Yeah.
I feel like I could have fucking,
there's a few times I've been there where I could have gotten in trouble.
Yeah.
Because he made fun of uh,
that guy in Canada made fun of a disabled.
Yes.
A person.
Yeah.
Little boy.
Went to sing for the pope or something.
Yeah.
And the line was like,
you know,
I don't expect that kid to live long and he ended up living subset or
cares,
whatever.
I mean joke,
but it's something like,
uh,
when I did my,
um,
my conjoined twins,
but I feel like that could have been taken in Canada the way I know.
It's terrifying.
If I have the right to say anything,
you certainly have the right to be offended if I can say anything I want.
You can say pension.
The said that.
And you can say,
Penn shouldn't have said that.
None of us should talk to him anymore.
And pension to said that we should,
he shouldn't have a job and pension has said that and he's not funny.
Pen shouldn't have said that.
We're going to put a pic,
it's out in front of the club and he should be able to go to that club.
All that is within your rights and very clearly within your rights,
but just like,
uh,
every individual has to make a decision on just because they can say something
doesn't mean they have to say it.
Individuals have to make the decision that just because you might feel offended
by something doesn't mean you have to announce you're offended.
Yeah.
So there you go.
It's a really,
really timely documentary.
It's,
it's weird.
These guys started making it right and it's all kind of exploded since then.
They covered that story about that woman who tweeted a,
she was on her way to South Africa.
Yeah.
That she was like,
I hope I don't get aids.
Just kidding.
I'm white and not the greatest job,
but who cares?
And she ended up losing her job.
She ended up having to change her name.
They couldn't even get her to be in the documentary because she's like,
I'm not fucking touching the subject again.
I got into so much trouble over.
I'd tweet.
I feel like this is such a cool Gig,
uh,
for you to get as soon as the best,
not only is it the cool gig of narrating something,
which is a good Gig,
but this topic every,
basically every comedian feels this way about it.
And you're the voice of the film.
Yeah.
I'm so,
I'm so private.
Ted Balaguer did it.
Okay.
So here's a little write up in maxim,
a new documentary.
Can we take a joke?
Presents us with their side of the issue directed by Ted,
by Alec are narrated by Comedian Christina [inaudible].
Keith,
did I say it right?
The film shows how luminaries like Gilbert Godfrey,
Penn Jillette least Leben Ellie,
Adam Carolla,
Jim Norton,
Heather McDonald have grappled with this trend in American culture.
Spoiler alert.
They're not too thrilled about it.
Um,
it looks like it's been doing well at the fit.
First of all,
services are great.
It's,
it's,
I don't know yet how to see it,
but it's called,
can we take a joke?
I think it just debuted.
It's really cool.
I can't wait to,
I haven't seen it.
I haven't seen it with my narration.
And it,
but I've seen it in like the,
the raw as I was narrating it.
So it's,
it's so cool.
I mean,
so be clear on the timely thing to,
to comedians
basically feel
the way that Penn just mentioned there that's basically summarizes.
Yeah.
Which is that you have the right to um,
feel any way you want to feel about a joke,
but it's the idea that your feeling that way outweighs everything else that is
outrageous.
Yeah.
Well,
and also like to have your feelings hurt.
It's fine,
but hurt feelings don't want people losing their jobs.
Yeah.
I'm like that woman,
I tweeted something,
okay,
yeah,
we get it.
It's really racially insensitive.
But did she deserve to lose her livelihood and have it ruined her life because
she said something,
she says something without thinking.
She was trying to be funny and fail.
Like it wasn't,
she wasn't inciting violence against.
People are playing clips that are like,
hey hiller you know what I mean?
Like she wasn't doing those things right.
Like Gilbert Gilbert lost his job.
He does the AFLAC.
Yeah.
AFLAC
voice because of tweets,
joke,
tweet,
you know,
they are,
they're obviously not the sweetest tweets,
but that's,
you know,
he's a comedian.
That's what he's known.
Yeah.
And he's a comedian who is known for being cantankerous.
And saying crazy shit.
So if you want the guy who's not going to say that,
don't hire Gilbert as your,
it's so corny,
like,
yeah.
Anyway,
you're going to you,
it's the cover a lot of other examples of what's happening,
especially on college campuses,
which is kind of really alarming because that's supposed to be where you debate
ideas of all kinds and now there's a resistance,
even debating ideas that are considered political.
Please.
Also this movement of I've seen amongst some comedians of supporting,
no,
yeah.
Political.
Correct.
So I guess I actually misspoke when I said this is the universal comedian,
um,
approach.
It's the universal good comedians response to that stuff.
So basically every comedian that I see defending that isn't worth a shit.
Yeah,
I agree.
So yeah.
It's um,
it's fucking terrible.
Yeah.
Well even,
um,
there was something I heard on the doctor Laura show.
I listened to her for a laugh where they,
uh,
there was someone in a university,
a Catholic university defending same sex marriage,
just being like,
I believe marriage is between a man and got thrown out of class and called a
bigot and the hatred and all this crap.
Offending cat,
the Catholic stance.
So not,
you said defending same sex marriage.
Oh,
sorry.
Defending traditional marriage.
Okay.
Sorry.
Like old school marriage and the,
um,
the teacher was like,
that's hateful.
How dare you,
like,
well,
okay,
maybe,
but why not debate it?
We not figure it out and this kid got in and just let that person think that you
care.
Yeah.
So interesting and interesting.
I know the world is,
it's a very interesting place
that comedians actually defend.
Oh,
the political correctness stuff I read,
I have not,
I've yet to see one good one.
Um,
it's always somebody who,
who basically walks around with a lot of feelings in their comedy.
So like,
they want that defended,
you know,
that that's kind of what they carry around is that they're,
they're,
they're very sensitive,
which is fine.
Right,
right,
right.
Um,
but I,
I haven't really seen many a working comics.
No,
no.
Working me that and also where do you draw the line?
Like how do you know what's not going to offend anybody?
What's the safe joke?
Am I going to tell it?
Talk,
tell jokes about balloons or is there some kind of balloon league that's going
to get mad?
Cause I'm harming the integrity of balloons.
You know,
it's,
yeah.
It's just,
it goes on and on.
There's no,
I know.
Oh,
that's makes me crazy.
It's a topic that makes me crazy.
It makes me crazy too.
Anyway,
go see it.
Can we take a joke?
Cuts out?
Um,
we have,
uh,
what is this a voicemail that came in from a fan yet?
But I play it.
How do we get that talent?
Some Italian lady is calling them.
Oh.
And the cheat sheet.
Okay.
I think getting Persian voicemails and Razah.
Joan.
Really?
Yeah.
Not as many.
It's only been like one in the last month or so.
Okay.
Um,
let's see.
We have this,
hello?
Is there the professional composer?
No.
Yeah,
it should be the first one in the fan mail section.
Oh,
it's not an inquiry.
I got you.
Yeah.
By the way,
it was really neat.
Um,
am I shows at flappers when I would walk up to stage to have fans yelling,
Hey Hitler,
uh,
here,
like I don't know how to respond to you right now.
Oh my God.
Not Everybody in this audience is a Miami guys and the same thing.
And the guy's like,
come on man,
Hitler.
And I'm like fuck me in my ass.
And the one guy was like,
after he goes,
I was going to give you a Heil Hitler.
And I go,
why don't you not?
Why are you parked this where it's at now?
Not I'm someone goes during the middle of my set,
I choose retarded.
And I started laughing and then I did the would you rather for the audience,
cause I had to feel like I had to fill them in.
Not so much time.
So good.
Broad that show to a screeching halt I had that.
Some people find funny,
some people might not,
people didn't not into it.
Yeah.
Alright.
A Fan mail.
Here we go to the mommy.
This may concern over the past few months,
I've woken up to occasional voicemails from a stranger in Italy or so.
I thought today she called during the day and she used the Italian version of my
name to greet me,
Matteo,
and I believe was trying to claim to know me instead of the usual Chow Paula
leading me to believe this may be a prank,
someone I know or maybe something far more sinister.
I beg for your help by seeing if any mommies out there can translate these
voicemails for me.
I must get to the bottom of this somehow.
Also,
the voicemails themselves are pretty funny and Italian,
but probably funnier if I knew what the Brown she was saying,
Huh?
I've sent the first voicemail from three months ago along with this email over
and out,
Matt.
So we've got to have a fluent Italian listener for sure.
Without a doubt.
I speak it.
I can translate it.
So now this makes more sense.
Uh,
let me see if I can play it now.
Let's see what,
so this is basically,
this person's in the same boat as you.
Yeah.
Um,
with the Persian voicemails.
Yeah.
That,
that were ended up being absolutely fucking hilarious.
and then I ate us who was a mental patient,
right?
They fled his life and then I was getting panicked.
Eight as voicemails and then Shanaze who's the nurse who's been getting a lot of
business proposals and Shanaz hasn't been answering.
Damn man.
So many people had that number.
So many people,
I don't know why.
Quick turnaround too.
I know.
Great.
At least I don't have bad credit.
The worst is getting a,
the creditor calls,
which happened on our last home line.
Gerald Brown are Shamara GME died.
[inaudible] the dop,
Chateau
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] to,
to,
to echo.
And we keep paying show [inaudible] normality.
If you showed me two time to child,
well,
a child,
I can basically translate this.
No,
I'm translating this.
I told you I speak Italian.
No,
no.
I really can basically translate that.
What is it?
Oh,
okay.
Would you want to go for it?
Well,
she's asking about the Volkswagen Passat or the echo.
Which one does I want to drive more?
Is that what you got?
A,
I got a little different.
First of all,
I don't think this is a prank.
I think this is a genuine phone call.
I'll tell you from my limited Italian and Spanish that is very close and a lot
of words what is going on is it sounds,
first of all,
definitely like an old woman.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Okay.
Sorry Gerald.
[inaudible]
so it's,
it's child power lies.
Hi Paula.
So I thought she was calling you my tale,
but she says blah.
So she's talking about that says who should
give me a shot?
Sham,
I'm sending you a thousand like I'm greeting you,
right?
Hello?
Yeah,
like a thousand hugs a hell,
hell or high alert.
Yeah.
Pop in Chateau [inaudible] and they knew Tali,
uh,
thinking of,
I dunno,
I forget if it was as if she's Ah,
fuck something about medicine.
It sounds like maybe
[inaudible]
yeah.
Wondering if you got the Passat or not.
Why keep paying show we know.
Depends who I'm thinking about,
right.
If you show him two times,
so Ciao Bella.
And then,
you know,
sending you hugs and bye,
bye.
Beautiful.
So
basically you were right there.
Is it the facade of the echo?
Right.
Basically what,
what's going for there?
That's so funny.
Yeah.
But I think as you,
you've got a genuine call man.
And the fact that you keep getting them,
that's the best kind that mean she's totally,
it's older.
It sounds to me it's all people who aren't clued in that the voicemail is not
their friends' phone numbers change.
Yeah.
It's not for you.
Um hmm.
Yeah,
the Persian I cute.
I still got the other one I'm thinking of.
MMM.
Languages.
We have a little bit of a debate going on here,
right?
Yeah.
Can I tell you about the dump I took this morning though?
Oh,
that'd be great.
But I feel like I didn't,
I haven't talked to you about this yet today.
We've been so busy.
But you know when you go to shit and you're like,
this is just going to be a run of the mill dump and then you look in the bowl
and you're like,
that's like a foot long.
Yeah.
That's what happened.
Wow.
That's neat.
Yeah.
Yeah,
but it's,
I didn't feel that long coming out and didn't feel like it would be that nice.
Yeah.
How many shifts have you taken today?
One really one.
And it's one 15 wow.
Some kind of record for Mr. I've got a problem.
Go too much.
You do this thing that's so unfair.
No matter when I'm taking a shit.
You Go.
Do you ever,
are you ever not shitting cause you always choose to take a shit when we're
doing something together as a family.
Like,
oh,
we're putting our son to sleep.
I got to shit or we're having a nice moment with people.
I got to go shit.
Or she called them.
We've got a shit as an excuse to get away from it.
I'm not using it.
I have to go.
Yeah.
Okay.
L'Aquila is a lacroix and we had this kind of the island of,
yeah,
right.
Saint Croix.
Now it's Lacroix.
Okay,
let's call him.
Let's call him right now.
Look
how to pronounce.
That's look cry.
What do you mean?
There's a,
let's see,
there's another,
like another video here.
Now in the same,
the same type of post says
from the company says Lacroix.
Right?
But how do you pronounce the word?
I don't know.
I mean,
they're saying Lacroix,
the company's saying Lacroix.
That's saying [inaudible].
Right.
So we're kind of,
I got emails from,
from listeners,
uh,
some of our French Canadian listeners saying,
Tommy's right,
Nicola,
but then you're sticking to,
well,
the fucking official pronunciation on their website is lacroix.
But then how could that be?
It says,
Lacroix rhymes with enjoy.
Right?
So maybe that's there.
Maybe there's an accent that we're not looking at an accent mark or something or
fee for some loud,
I don't fucking know.
I mean,
can we call them right now?
You want to try to call him?
Yeah.
Okay.
Let me see here.
MMM.
Well we could end up getting into like a real debate with them though,
right?
I mean,
you feel like that's something you want to do right now?
Yeah.
Okay.
Let me see here.
Um,
how do you propose that we do,
do you think we should just call them out on what we're looking for?
I have also some other questions.
Really.
Okay.
Um,
La Quilla water
phone.
Okay.
Is there,
um,
do you want to ask about the uh,
the burps or no?
Yeah,
let's ask her.
I want it to lie.
Why?
Why does it make you burp so much?
Okay.
Um,
okay.
Here we go.
Found the phone number
one.
Can I hear me?
I've talked to any of that thing,
right?
I don't know.
I think so.
Here we go.
Yeah.
Did you get through last time anymore?
Hmm.
We should come in with a message for them.
I know I fucking franchisees and their work.
We are on holiday.
They're American.
No look
French drain.
Mccoy water consumer services Lacroix.
Thank you for calling our consumer service contact center.
Currently all representatives are busy assisting other customers.
Your call is very important to us.
We just get better as soon as he was teaching.
Please leave your name,
telephone number and a brief message so we may return your call promptly.
Thank you again for calling our consumer service contact center and have a
wonderful day.
Begin speaking after the tone,
then hang up when you were finished or press any key for further options.
I love on Julie sees a young Pia.
I'm calling about the uh,
the,
the mango.
So daily.
She seems so nice.
I wonder him.
He make him sad.
Burp.
I makes some much gas,
but all the gas comes out of the top.
[inaudible] them and my wife,
for one,
I wanted the Bolo type a classic.
But Eh,
I wonder if you have any advice.
He's so good.
Please message me.
Eh,
eh,
how say [inaudible] come
so far.
Yeah,
we left a message.
We'll be hearing back from them shortly,
I'm sure.
Yeah.
Um,
let's call on it.
I do need to talk to them.
I feel like I have some questions too.
I let's do it.
Yeah,
there's a lot to talk about it.
You Become Lacroix happy in this house.
So I've ordered some off of amazon.com using our banner.
We click@thebottomofthehomepageonyourmomchosepodcast.com and I've ordered a
passion fruit mango and their strawberry one.
It's a real good,
uh,
it's really,
yeah,
no luck quad today.
But there's already one that came out as Lacroix.
She
said Lacroix.
Yup.
Yup,
Um,
yeah,
so there's a bunch.
Oh,
there's some now means,
and I'm saying that we should get to a,
these are the,
uh,
the gym Jones ones.
These are really good,
I think.
Um,
let me pull these up.
The,
let's see,
is it the Jim Jones talks.
Here we go.
Let's see if these are the ones,
this is it,
right?
Right here.
So tell me what you think of these cars that you have,
like these really strict rules about what counts as a no,
I mean,
or what I'm saying or
is nothing that could be for ingles,
some clashing.
It was dead.
I told you the game is about machismo.
Who's the macho bravado smelling the cameras.
The goods.
You already said,
you understand,
you smell me.
You know,
that's pretty,
is that what he said?
Yeah.
He said,
you understand the start and then he was just smelling.
These are all different categories
you did.
Diamonds is about who's the biggest Alastair.
You understand?
Once you get that bullet and pot,
you dealing with Nigga Sunni ghetto,
you dig things.
I've never had nothing temperamental.
And the worst ones is the Niggas from the ghetto.
That was pussy when they came up and when they got a little bit of money,
they all of a sudden turn hard rock.
You understand?
First of all,
I do feel what he's saying and everything,
but at the chain,
he's got a different chain than the one you have.
Yeah,
I have that.
The old school Dukey road,
but yeah,
he's got totally something else there.
Are you going to be getting earrings too?
It ain't no way to prevent it that she can go on and they get a spelling bee.
It's like Niggas that come up in the road and you get pumped on in life and in
turn it to a cup and they start Punkin Niggas and you like,
Oh,
you must've been a faggy when you came up.
Wow.
Smell.
Whoa,
whoa.
We don't call them that anymore.
It's fuck boy,
boy please.
With a cock sucker to turn to cop in Charlotte and how sat on us.
You did?
Yeah,
he's definitely calling out Ricky rozay right there.
Right.
And that's what Niggas in a game like these niggas been fag coming up any of the
name.
Then I'll say,
yeah,
I still be outside the hood shit,
but down beat it.
Yeah.
I've been to a lot of places in America and I'm talking about the hoods
scrolling.
Niggas know me.
Don't know me.
You did.
I liked that.
He actually made it mixes everything together.
I like it too.
I think this is a whole new level of,
you know what I'm saying?
The guy really play.
It's playful.
The way he interlaces you smell me.
You dig,
you understand?
Yeah.
This is a,
this guy is varsity level.
I'm saying you can dip his toe and each of the different pools.
That's right.
This guy has taken the game to a whole other level.
We have to open up a whole new category.
Now this is varsity.
Well when you see him,
these niggas got home security.
We're fucking badges.
Smell me one in front of them.
One of the American,
I'm like,
they fucking him.
You smell me smelling me.
But the chicken and the beef shit smelly.
Wow.
I was amazed.
Really.
Although neat,
neat video.
Thank you.
Yeah,
I mean then he's got,
you know,
this might be a different smell.
Means here.
These are really good.
This is um,
yeah,
this is really a like you would say a really neat,
you know,
oh,
that's the wrong clip.
Um,
so because he's so advanced you would consider this what?
Its own its own thing.
Yeah.
He's elevated the game.
This is a whole new category.
Course.
Smell me.
Swelling,
swelling,
smell me,
smell me.
Sally smell me slowly,
slowly.
Slumming.
Smell me.
Smelling,
smelling
an amazing,
I love it.
A smell me super cut.
We've never even had that before.
That's really impressive.
On game.
Yeah.
I do like that a lot.
What's this gentleman's name?
Jimmy.
Just smell me.
Is swelling,
swelling,
swelling.
Smell me,
smell me smelly.
Smell me slowly.
Slowly.
Slumming.
Smell me.
Swami.
I do.
I do so dumb.
Yeah.
Not a fun dumb thing.
What a fun,
dumb thing to do,
sir.
Um,
are you excited for your sister visiting this weekend?
Uh,
yeah actually,
uh,
you know,
it's pretty cool.
I mean she's got a lot of shit going on so it's,
I haven't seen her while she hasn't met our son yet.
That's exciting.
Um,
yeah,
this isn't Maria.
This is Jane.
The other one's coming.
Jane's coming in.
I'm excited.
I can't wait.
I think my cousin Julie is going to come over to have a little
family get togethers.
Your other,
your other cars shotty and no,
I don't think so.
She's too busy.
She's still on other stuff.
He knows in the Rock Hall of fame this weekend.
And um,
this is the kind of thing that I
imagine will be in their way.
If you're in charge of submissions,
the world is burning.
I love it.
Let's masturbate
you like
who's this guy?
How
you pull in fucking them.
Paulus very masturbate people at the United natsume they masturbate.
Water color,
masturbate,
lollipop.
Lollipop.
You would have gotten to this.
Yeah.
No,
this is true.
I know this band.
This is called fad gadget.
I swear this guy is a band.
I had an nine.
Ah,
sold me on it.
There is a band.
There's a band named bad guy.
Does that guy looks just like this.
You definitely would have gone to the show though,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
No.
This would have been what day dated that guy.
Not dated,
but that's what I've been my jam in high school.
You would have hung out with this dude.
I'd be like,
this is the coolest thing I've ever seen.
Yeah.
People living in substandard,
not,
hey bozo.
I've fought acrylic paint.
This is my shot.
The bus shelter on the old,
let's just,
some of the 17 year old boys masturbate all day mass.
His message is true
drugs,
drugs.
Do we know this is artist
drugs?
Drugs.
Sound like your father.
I know because he's right.
My father was right.
Everybody's on drugs.
It
I'm good.
Yeah.
Well that's your boyfriend.
I was going to tell you,
I'm like,
how's a,
Shawty is a really into the holiday clothing for the babies.
You know,
like she has to dress up her son for every holiday.
Yeah.
I don't do that.
I don't believe,
I think it's child abuse.
Really?
It's Saint Patrick's day dry.
Your two month old up in green things like he doesn't know where the fuck he is.
He doesn't know what Saint Patrick's Day.
Not for a while and now when they're babies.
Right.
No stupid.
It's for you.
It's for you to dress up your child long time.
Yeah.
That's true for a long time.
And Yeah.
You remember last week I had the lady lifting ways,
right?
Hmm.
So I got another lady screaming,
but she's getting a tattoo.
Oh,
okay.
Hi.
All
right.
Chile.
Look how calm he gets mad.
He gets mad eventually.
Super Unprofessional.
Yeah.
That's the problem.
It's killing me.
I should.
Or whites.
Yeah.
That's so great.
This lady.
Okay.
Oh,
I love it.
I love it man.
Okay.
Yeah.
I like,
it's right after I said I need you to like calm down so I can do this.
That's why you don't get tattoos drunk.
Right.
Cause it's way worser.
Shit got way worse.
You don't want him to know.
What are you going to some tattoos,
you know,
I've been wondering.
Um,
I've actually been offered by a lot of people for free.
One,
two artists.
I don't know.
I probably would do something to start like a neck thing or I think I see you
like an old English chest piece.
Hmm.
Your son's name on it and my name on it.
Oh yeah.
What do you think you would think chest is the way to go?
Huh?
Do you want to start off small or knuckle?
I,
you know,
I'm a huge fan of these.
I think these are the job stoppers are the fucking doing.
Maybe upper arms should be the first step.
I don't know.
Can I tell you lately and this is real,
real tog yeah,
I've been,
I like how it looks on a woman on the inner,
what does this reform?
Yeah.
I kind of like,
I want like an anchor really.
Really?
I kind of do or like a fisherman spear.
I don't know,
are tried and I don't know why I like that.
Go for it man.
Or maybe just some spider webs on my elbow.
There you go.
That's more,
I see that more for you.
Yeah.
Or something on my boobs.
So when I feed my son,
he can do,
you should put see tigers pause.
Okay.
That's classy.
Like on your chest.
Yeah.
Like what's her name?
Not Rihanna was eve.
Eve has,
yeah.
And I would do like a series of them were like,
there's pause down from your chest all the way down your abdomen and then right
above your coach there's a bunch of spilled milk.
Okay.
That's,
that's where the kid is going to feed.
You know,
I've got one for Ya.
Okay.
I think we should do one in all my i's a vive,
not Betsy top prints.
[inaudible] prints pub.
Right.
Same thing.
Same breathing down your chest.
Oh,
that big pile of shit.
Um,
I in your butthole.
A pile of shit or my butthole swirl.
Okay.
I'm,
I'm digging it.
I just an Arrow to your mouth.
Dick's go here.
That's pretty,
that's pretty not true.
We can put Dick's had been here on your face.
Yeah.
No,
I'm serious.
Would you still love me if I got the job stoppers?
No.
Fuck you money.
No,
I think I want to get that.
I would not know.
Do you think Ellis with mine and it was mommy took him to school now they want
with knuckle dads.
I think the worst part of getting fuck you money on your notes would be that you
don't have it,
so that's why,
but no one knows that.
They'll just think I do.
Yeah,
I know.
I'd rather,
I'd rather wait.
How about this?
We'll make a deal.
We get like a nine figure net worth.
One day we can go get that tattooed on your,
on your knuckles.
I can't wait.
Yeah,
I think it's probably a couple of years away.
Are you serious that you really would have,
would you ever consider a tattoo for real though?
Yeah,
I would consider a tattoo.
Really?
Yeah.
You want to go get sun?
No,
I just,
because it would have to be one that that I want to get.
Yeah,
like a portrait of someone.
portrait would be good.
Yeah.
I'm kind of a portrait portrait of me.
On your face.
On your,
by your kid.
No,
I don't dig those.
How about a rapper,
Eric B and Rakim?
Yeah.
I'll get Eric B and Rakim tattooed on me.
Sure,
no problem.
Yeah.
Well,
it means a lot to you.
I might get like dad mouth tet tattooed on me.
That means a lot to you.
Immortalized on your body is forever.
Did I started my DJ career with a tattoo?
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
I know what you should get since you're a comedian.
Microphone or the microphone cord wrapped all the way through those theater
faces.
The happy,
sad.
Yeah.
Or I'll put smile.
Why don't you always write that on myself?
Smile.
Why don't Ya.
Yeah.
I love making people laugh.
How about smile now?
Cry Later.
It's my now cry later.
I like that one a lot.
Yeah.
But that's kind of like AASC.
Hey homie.
Shit.
Old smile now.
Cry Later.
Locked up homes.
That's total present tattoo.
Yeah.
That's why it's funny,
you know?
Yeah.
You got to cry when it's time to cry.
Am I was 13 yeah.
Miss 13 that's cool.
Mmm
God,
I'm still kind of riding that high of a DJ.
Be Crazy.
Look Shit.
I know.
I can feel it.
There's so much brewing in the air.
Yeah.
Possibilities,
potentials,
potentiality.
Oh God.
This is a juggle it.
Beauty pageant.
Okay.
Yeah.
I just wanted to make sure that phase covers the whole screen.
All right.
Ooh.
A lot of people think Joe lots are just like,
they're just these big horse.
No.
When I go to the gathering and shows and other girls,
we can just sit and be girls.
You're not preppy.
You're not going to judge me for anything.
Like we can sit down and have a one on one alone conversation and relate to so
many things in so many ways that not any other people can really relate to.
Oof.
If I was a judge
and those were the first few people that came up on the contest,
my score would be
both,
but can I tell you how much would you love it if one of these broads showed up
at a legitimate beauty contest?
That's true.
That would be it.
Then I started watching Miss America all over again.
One of these Lumitex showed up.
Can we do that?
Can we subvert a beauty pageant like that?
Yeah.
I mean like,
I guess that's kind of what they're doing.
Yeah.
So that's sort of the,
uh,
the,
you know,
my point of it.
Yeah.
I like it.
All right.
That's cool.
But still score well.
All right.
Why is that not such a dad thing?
Oof.
Huh.
Now do it.
What do you think your dad would say about these ladies?
I'd be really upset.
Is this your first gathering?
And my dad does your,
your first beauty contest.
I won 2009.
I need a microphone disappear.
Where?
In the front?
In the bag?
Yeah.
Wow.
So she put it up on a microphone or coach?
Yeah.
That's pretty cool.
Actually.
I'm a bigger fan now.
I respect that.
My Dad would be really upset by this too.
Oh,
I should this woman I saw ugly God.
Fuck,
fuck in the flood.
Look good.
These pigs.
Oh my.
Um,
well my father has no tolerance for unattractive women.
Yeah.
Disdain for unattractive people.
Like how dare you be ugly fat too,
right?
Oh,
fatness is inexcusable.
Yeah.
He always makes jokes about me.
He's like,
does he?
Well,
he's always like,
oh,
see you lost some weight.
And I was like,
Oh yeah.
He's like,
no,
this is a miss cyanide here.
Talking about her.
Uh,
our journey started with you sideline.
The juggle that rapper who lives in our home studio with her boyfriend's
sidekick.
Okay.
Pig Feed saw.
Can't break me down.
I bet they're going,
I hate me now.
There's no safety now.
So,
so far I'll say,
I'd rather watch her compete in the beauty part.
Then the rapping part point taken now in the concert is between Nick Hark,
the guy from the real plastic surgeon in Beverly hills or DJ poor grind,
whatever her name is,
Miss Cyanide,
ms cyanide,
which of these concerts now listen,
you gotta go?
Yeah,
go watch the whole show.
So we have Nick Hawk doing his repartee wraps.
We have the Beverly hills plastic surgeon who like I dedicated.
A lot of times when you're in surgery,
you need something to go wrong.
Otherwise what are you there to fix?
Okay.
That guy.
And he's like,
okay,
he's last.
Right.
I just,
I just decided this last,
I think he's last.
I think it's the hardest one because here's why it's bad,
but it's bad in something that I,
that wouldn't necessarily,
like if it was good,
you know,
it's not even your John.
Right,
right.
So just so I feel like I could have a lot more laughs and a lot more fun even
with it being bad at nick.
I know that,
you know,
that's a problem is that there's so much more to laugh at at nick.
The nick hoc show.
Yeah.
Cause he's gonna be,
you know,
posturing real sincere Yang and yeah.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Ms Cyanide is just kind of sloppy and all over the place.
Yeah.
What I've seen so far,
she's a little more Polish.
Yeah.
One more time.
Take me down.
I'm,
that's your play in this song now.
It was rad.
Yeah.
About haters and the shit that you deal with people because I'm,
I'm up here,
I'm feeling great.
I'm on top of it.
I'm doing what you said I couldn't do.
Yeah.
Cyanide is a and the juggle at BD pageant that's held on the last day of the
gathering every year.
Alright.
Oh,
I liked this.
I like the cyanide going for it.
I did too.
And I will say of all three at least,
she's really kind of in it like she's genuinely one thing more than at this than
I do at traditional beauty pageants is that they're really doing,
this is obviously the talent portion so far.
We know that one of them raps and one of them shoved them Mike up or coach.
And I would rather see that at Miss America than that bullshit when they're
looking at head fucking and I flipped this in the air and then I catch it might
not be the best if they're like,
I can hide this in my pussy.
Yeah,
that's Ms Iowa.
that'd be great.
Yeah.
The,
I understand it's to subvert beauty pageants then why have a beauty pageant at
all?
Like when not be the ultimate subversion is to just not have a beauty pageant.
Well,
no,
because I think in this case what they're saying is those beauty pageants are so
misguided and,
and their interpretation of beauty.
So one dimensional that we're going to bring women to the table that aren't
traditionally beautiful.
Right.
And the one who shoves a microphone up or pussy is the fucking best.
Clearly not where the wrapper and their talents.
So that's kind of cool.
Last year sign I participated for the first time she kind of blew it,
but she's been practicing law
summer to get back on stage of it.
For her I was really nervous and I got really,
really fucking high.
Like before I was like I got smoke a bowl and my brain was like,
oh fuck you forgot the rest of your lyrics.
I like her,
hey,
you know why she saw her mistake?
She knew how to correct it and she's going to move on.
Actually the thing I respect the most is that she went back.
That's good for dude.
That's tough.
Huge fan of cyanide already.
I wouldn't want to watch wraps that long.
Has um,
has fucken as a comedian forgotten the line for sure.
Panic inducing.
It's the worse.
That's why I don't do drugs.
I can't even really drink coffee before shows.
I don't like to do anything before it either.
Do it straight
cyanide pack,
300 Jello shots and most of the belongings in our home before setting off
someone might not have a good second year at this maybe,
which she in fact had had been saving up for all year.
Oh Man.
This is like their whole life.
No,
they love it.
She spending it on Jello shots.
Good for them.
Gassing up the van,
back kid and I are going to go rip it a wrap.
All right man.
I'm actually really into this now.
Yeah.
Um,
I like this look.
Actually I'm being serious.
I like a ball hog.
I've always liked him.
All you have always like,
are you going to do it to our son now you don't like it when Peter wrote the
kids,
can I tell you something?
I don't like to inflict my personal style on a kid.
It's like it.
Unless he asks for it.
It's not my place.
I know I like the Ramones is my kid.
I have to like the Ramones.
He's not an extension of me.
He's his own little dude.
Do I want to put clash shirts on my kid?
Yeah,
but I won't.
It's his fucking,
he's a person I don't like when people do that.
Fuck this always happens to me.
You don't like doing that at all,
right?
It's just not fair.
It's like he didn't ask to be a fan of the shit that I like.
Yeah.
Here we go.
We have an after party with Dj Clay,
which is gonna be quite the same.
Holy Shit.
That just
more like we can do a lot of really ratchet stuff about getting in trouble.
Yes,
exactly.
Gears.
Awesome.
That'll be here.
And what about that too?
What about that is my first,
this is what I'm talking about now.
I didn't realize that these were just like soggy underwear that he's wearing.
I thought this was an actual short and not so much into the front of the outfit.
I'm into the back of it though.
But what about this part of the front?
I like that.
I like what it stands for.
A dues red.
Huh?
Super.
It's a lot of crazy tattoos here.
Is this a grenade on his hand?
I liked her.
She is just like,
Hey,
what's up?
She's like,
yeah,
this is normal.
He's like,
this is how I roll.
Well,
Gigi Allen,
look,
little shout out.
He's wearing the same GG.
If you combine the girls clip from earlier about eating ass,
you look at this.
I feel like a lot of what she said would come true in here.
It wouldn't smell great.
Wouldn't taste the best,
but overall not that bad.
Not that bad.
Yeah.
What do you think?
And I was better than it used to.
I think this guy has got the worst ass.
If anybody in the world.
No,
but bad because bad.
What'd you eat?
His ass.
No,
I would not,
but I don't think it would smell good either.
Let's jump ahead to Miss Miss Sinai's performance.
I want to see.
Yeah.
Does she redeem herself this year?
Well here,
this is bright before she goes up.
I think right here.
Poor girl.
I hope she's been practicing in front of audiences.
That's the key.
There's a lot more people out there.
Then last year when I did this,
I was like,
wow,
you can do it.
She's nervous.
Come on,
Batman.
Come on.
Come on home girl.
Um,
so this is a clip here where,
let's see.
There's some good,
all right.
There's goods and contestants.
Or is this a drawing that looks like a tattoo baby boy,
baby.
Here she goes.
I got one.
I'm so invested in Ms Cyanide now.
Yeah.
I want to know she
[inaudible].
Okay,
I'll tell you this already.
I like it.
Her live performance is better than her booth performance.
You know when the one that she did at home
had a fraction of this energy?
Well,
she's feeling it.
She's the,
she's fucking on it.
I think she's,
she's killing me.
Yeah.
Whoa.
My feeling is that
awesome.
So she's,
she's feeling good about herself right now.
Here's what you've been waiting for.
Jeans,
the,
uh,
the results.
So you ready?
We have the results.
Do you think how you think she did?
Yeah,
I'd say she killed it.
But knowing that last year someone put a microphone up there,
Posey and won,
she's going to get beaten up by some dumb cunt that does something stupid.
Just like everything in Showbiz.
Yeah.
Right.
Here we go.
Testing.
What's her fucking,
I don't know what else she did.
What she did.
I don't know.
Well,
so what ms up cyanide.
I will,
I'll vote for you.
Good job.
We support you.
Well,
good for her.
That's really hard to do now.
I thought the Juggalos were supposed to be nonjudgmental.
Ooh,
yeah,
yeah.
That about you're not supposed to boot people off stage.
Um,
by the way,
I ordered my DJ equipment through your mom's house podcasts that come right.
And it was on banner.
I can see your eyes roll,
just so you know.
Yeah,
I got speakers.
I got,
uh,
I got the time.
Are we done the show?
Is it?
Yeah,
we got to get everything wrapped up already.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
We got to get into this.
So last week we did a fill her up right.
Sealers,
song contest.
Right.
Here's what happened.
We have a tie to submissions have gotten the most amount of votes,
but then a wildcard,
late submission came in and blue band deemed it's so good and he said we have to
listen to it.
Okay,
so first I'll play you the first two.
Um,
the first two that,
that have the highest votes so far in the contest.
Okay.
Hello.
Just us from John.
Love it.
This one from Holly.
Clean too concise.
Yolo.
Ready to do this shit man.
Okay.
All right.
So that's by Ali also.
Great.
And then here's the,
uh,
the late submission that,
I haven't even heard yet,
but I've heard is good from Rick.
Here we go.
She's like a machine.
You just want to fill
holes with them anyway.
Really like twice.
I'll tell you what I did.
This was really great.
It also stuck to the Latin flavor of curry thing.
Pretty good man.
That's really good.
Well,
might as well play around it.
Filler up sealer shy,
what do you say?
Yeah.
Okay.
So tell her up and steal her shot.
Presidential presidential edition.
The presidential nominee is issue,
right?
So we have Donald Trump or Bernie Sanders.
Yes.
For the men.
Right.
What are you thinking?
Yeah.
What do you thinking in terms of those two?
Because that's not exactly the most desirable filler up material as a lady.
What you know about it either.
That's why it's a good one.
It's good when they're both really,
really hot or both really,
really not.
The thing is okay.
Right,
okay.
Yeah.
Is that you want to separate the personality from the Sexual Act.
That's always the key to a successful fill her up.
Right.
Cause you don't,
you're not really talking about the person,
but you're letting the personality,
sexual side,
you're letting the personality dictate what the sexuality is in a way.
Right,
right.
I mean I kind of imagine it's obvious that Donald is a selfish megalomaniac,
narcissistic and sergeant historical.
It's going to be a horrible,
yeah,
but Bernie's so timid and such a Beta male that it might be just really
horrendous and he's old.
He just got into that.
I got to say that guy knows how to eat a box.
Bernie,
why'd he say that?
I could just see it.
I just feel like it's,
it's part of the foundation.
At his funeral there are going to talk about how he used to eat pussy like
nobody else.
I can feel it.
Know he was part of those civil rights marches and things.
I mean,
he's a giver.
You know a guy cares about the other man or in the case of in the bed,
you care.
He wants you to finish first.
That's what he's all about.
But I don't want it to last very long.
Like I kind of almost want the selfish lay here so that it's just over like
Trump,
just big arcs and then we'll get,
get the fuck outta here.
You know what I mean?
And will tell you to get the fuck out.
Right?
For sure.
Tell him good luck.
Good luck.
In that case.
I don't want this to be a drawn out because Bernie,
he's going to light the candles were talking sensible masage lavender smells to
question the hundred candle bath.
What's wrong with that?
I don't want it with Bernie
grain last.
He's a sexy mailman man.
Unless he got the mailman length.
I think conversation would be fascinating.
I think you'd have a nice,
I don't want that.
Okay.
Oh,
you just want to get yours off.
I just want to get in and get out of this ordeal.
No,
I want to get out of the filler up sealer shut.
I don't want to participate in this one.
Okay.
So I just want to get in and out quick and the Donald is going to be the easiest
way out.
Wow.
I got to tell you.
Real curve ball.
Didn't expect that answer.
Real.
What are you?
You're picking Bernie.
Oh,
massage.
First of all,
you know,
he would be like,
I'm not a gay man.
I know you're not a gay man,
but we both got to come.
So,
uh,
what do you need me to do your bowls?
And I'd be like,
Bernie,
just do what you would do to your own balls,
you know?
And I think he would be,
yeah,
I think,
I think it would be unbearable with,
with the done bearable.
But then again,
he's just like a frat boy as a man.
Choosing between those two.
I think it's much easier.
Maybe because I can't speak as a woman,
as a man,
you gotta go with Bernie.
He's going to be much more gentle,
much more caring.
He's still going to be like,
do you come to go?
And he'll be nice and there's more involved with but fucking them or as vaginal.
Donald's just going to come in drunk like a frat guy and just prison pound you
and it'll be done in 30 seconds and I'll throw a towel you and they'll be like,
great.
And sod gate.
Huge suck.
You gotta drink some of that milk.
Okay.
And the next for the ladies.
So you and I are opposed on this issue,
this highway high ticket items are we?
And the next one is Hillary or the fear in her Nina.
Carly Fiorina.
Carla Lorela.
Lafonda Nina.
For me it's easy.
Carly has that ice queen.
Fucking almost like dominatrix lecturer from house of farts.
Yeah.
Ah,
I like Carly's style.
Meaning she's a meanie and like it,
it turns me on,
I feel like,
and she was the CEO,
I think of IBM.
So I'd be like,
what are out what our acquisitions and mergers lately.
Tell me about like the first IPO you where it should be like eat this from
behind.
You know,
we like her,
but that's more of a power bitch.
Yeah.
She was a total power bitch and um,
I could see myself being very excited by her.
See,
I think Hillary is your classic closet.
Lez She's definitely a lesson college.
Yeah.
And then she was like,
I can't be gay because I got,
I want this political life.
I got Mary,
I'll bill here.
Bill seems acceptable.
So I think Hillary is a varsity level.
Lez and if you want to go with that experience,
she's your girl.
She's got years of eating box experience.
I bet.
Wow.
See I think,
I feel like Carly would put cigarettes out on my mouth.
Yeah.
She wet and then she'd be like,
I gotta pee.
I'd be like,
okay,
I'll wait here.
And she'd be like,
no,
open up your mouth.
Okay.
I mean,
should piss out the ass.
She's alone more.
Yeah.
Domineering and whatnot.
I know,
I'm excited thinking about like it's actually going to happen.
I think Carly's over using Carly emceeing.
Carla.
Yeah.
But I feel like she's too,
yeah,
I dunno.
I don't want to power budge.
I can't deal with it really well cause I'm kind of an Alpha.
I think Hillary's more of like the seventies college list.
That's what you want.
Yeah.
I like when I'm old Carly,
like here's,
here's Carly.
I'm eating her butt.
And then she's looking back,
like you said,
all you got.
Right.
You see,
I mean,
it's just,
this is attractive.
Right,
right,
right.
I like her.
I know Trump made a horrific comment about,
no,
I feel like Douche bag.
I think between the two,
there's no context for me.
I disagree.
I think aesthetically I like Hillary.
What's better?
I'm,
I like blondes,
you know?
Yeah.
I'm partial to,
I'd never been out with a blonde before.
Really?
Nope.
Um,
yeah.
This here,
right?
This is,
this is me.
This is her.
After I come look right,
they come in those balls.
She was like,
you got any common those bulls and then I do.
And then she goes,
that's it.
No,
she insults the come load,
the amount of load.
You call that a load there.
You call that a load.
Yeah.
[inaudible] look small.
Mm.
How many balls do you have?
Half of one.
Yeah.
Not impressed as fiar Nina.
I go,
where should I come?
And she goes right over here.
Ah,
yeah.
Yep.
That would be it.
Yeah.
I like her.
I choose her.
I can't believe you're choosing Hillary,
but it makes sense.
Well,
I know,
but you're right that maybe she has a lot of less experience.
Countless.
I,
I wouldn't be surprised that she really knows her.
She knows all the tricks and she's from that era of like,
there's the protests,
uh,
heroin,
Billy and yeah,
college.
She's got that classic Lez 60 seventies bless.
Like full Bush,
uh,
free love.
Lez Right.
That's the violent one.
Yeah.
Just like whatever man would you got?
I'll tell you get like,
just free love and Farley puts a leash on me.
She was like,
come on man.
It's a different energy altogether.
She's too dominant for me.
It's not going to work.
We have a,
what's it sound to go out to?
There's a o,
m c.
Oh,
see now I'm saying no.
Saying there's a challenge and then there's a disk.
Which one should I play?
The spark challenge as far as challenge.
Okay.
Not I'm saying,
I'm guys,
as always,
thank you for listening to your mom's house,
podcast.com please email us anything you want.
A submission,
a video,
a link,
a thought,
a question.
Your mom's podcast@gmail.com uh,
the Facebook page is facebook.com/your mom's house podcasts.
It just got over 10,000 lakes.
Hey,
ah,
my tickets to my live standup shows.
All right,
Tom,
cigarette.com/shows a Christina's are@thousandranch.com.
Follow me on Twitter at times to girl.
I follow Christina at Christina p a I will work on getting some social media
stuff going for my deejaying career that's coming soon.
Also horrible and as always,
visit the site at your mom's house,
podcast.com anything else?
Jeans.
That's it.
Thanks for listening.
Mommy's thanks mommy.
I love you.
She's like Trump machine.
You just want to fill the wrong one.
That's the wrong one.
Sorry.
Oh,
okay.
Fuck mixed martial.
Our stock car.
Fuck crazy sports fights.
Fuck the world boxes scenes.
Fuck all that can amaze sys to raw Arie.
Last one at eight for rails.
Doe a crazy throw your gloves up,
dog.
It's for charity.
Kiss me doing 20 minutes says that.
Hell,
I already talk his town walking Bandelier,
you shadow box like a fool.
I'm a colon and they can't even Jimmy Channel.
And you can't even fathom them.
You God is good homie.
But you can't even get mad at him cause I'm really bad at it.
I mean your brain crazy.
We inhabit it.
It's like an Indian in the cupboard in the cabinet like l Ron Hubbard.
We shadow priest at crazy Paladin fuck led pay duty and handle a gin.
Some say it ain't right that I bourbon to the MC.
Fuck it.
Yeah,
I shit a lot.
I've gone to brew up a pot,
going to be a wild bitch talking Tom Bonds come out with Jack it like a
crocodile.
They've got them shotguns and we all got something.
So we talked on the Stromae boys hitting home runs at leisure.
Show crazy that a freestyle Morrisey's your you speak in broken Spanish dude.
Take a brief look at your eyebrows like row.
Here's a tweezer crazy picking seashells by the seashore popping on Weezer the
sweater song.
Crazy.
Wish we could all just get along.
I'm going to give you a tease.
The slow you're going to end up in the freezer.
Wow.
I'm going to use the clean of a status quo.
Yukon or yell top Fargo,
Bro.
I'm at the Largo.
Red Car is sold out show you need a new at Tarago black tar pit you funky lot.
How gear I'd be sitting.
So what?
Tell area one every 1530 minutes drawing some creepy ass art.
Making some creaky ass forest with some guns.
Sit until my toes norms.
I got the run because I got the runs home.
Meet we shit.
And Times don't act like you don't know me.
Ring around my bum's Salami.
No Baloney.
Got To be positive on your mom.
He's like,
I'm a calm me dry in the tsunami lion.
AMMAS soggy but it makes for a good story in the hood.
Like where's the liberal restore?
Rihad don't know the territory.
Crazy.
Topanga making tea buns.
Cory Chogm be Tom.
It crazy be Jerry cat and mouse and your stayed mommy till six in the morning.
Somebody at the door is FedEx.
Sam.
Shit like that.
Going to make this mommy my ex.
We're going to give it to your crazy on the road.
Shadow boxing and looking like teapots delivered through year.
You'll pay by boy crazy either.
Whoop ass.
Is it Tom or black?
Ain't no sound effect given white Jews,
old ladies in a heart attack the farthest back and think I need to blue.
But that's not the point.
That's not the school accent.
Some point shit.
We're talking about points we Jehovah you talking to the noise,
turtle head poke and shadow box and swoop.
Swoop.
They go in the year crazy fans done disappeared shells.
No to all the peers before we'd spark crazy.
Bring a spare pair of shorts.
You all good on health care,
you take care of,
you're going to need intensive care.
This warfare I c u t bunk,
plenty of who gets some footwear.
Nike's to gonna Dunk on you say a Lord's prayer or too crazy.
You Jason,
Tommy,
Freddy.
Make them your nightmare on elm street roof.
The day you beware retrude talk in Paris shoe on your cowboy boots.
San Jose doesn't give up on you.
You shot time to electric cue.
I'm crashed.
Time to band the cuckoo crazy destined to shit.
And it ain't even gonna Arrest Dude.
It ain't never gonna read.
And so Tom Segura step in the ring.
We're crazy.
Lows.
You shall sell to your mom's house.
[inaudible] DOT com shall self to this deep growth carcass shall sell servers,
new showtime specials.
They don't say nothing about way [inaudible] a
shell selves.
All my DTA.
You know how you hear Danny?
I've seen girls was okay shall cells
two.